La Guerra Fría, el proceso de construcción
europeo, las principales instituciones globales
de nuestros días…
todo esto tiene un mismo punto de partida:
1945, la victoria aliada en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial, el momento más decisivo del siglo
XX.
Este megaconflicto supuso un antes y un después
para la geopolítica global, dando forma desde
entonces a las relaciones internacionales.
Sin embargo, amigos, hoy día, en 2023, hay
señales de que podríamos estar acercándonos
a otro de esos momentos decisivos.
Pensadlo un segundo: La caída de la Unión
Soviética generó entonces la ilusión de
una época dominada por Estados Unidos, la
gran superpotencia económica y militar.
Quizás fue verdad en los años 90, pero la
crisis económica de la Gran Recesión, el
desgaste sufrido en Irak y el fracaso colosal
en Afganistán han puesto en problemas al
imperio americano, sacudido además internamente
por la extrema polarización política generada
por el trumpismo y sus oponentes.
Estados Unidos no está en su mejor momento
y, claro, la pregunta es evidente:
¿Quién podría tener interés en aprovechar
esta aparente debilidad?
La Rusia de Putin sin lugar a dudas.
Como principal heredera de la Unión Soviética,
Rusia conserva un arsenal nuclear temible.
Y desde el Kremlin no dejan de recordarnos
que el apoyo de Occidente a Ucrania no saldrá
gratis.
(El expresidente ruso Medvedev advierte que
estamos más cerca que nunca de la Tercera
Guerra Mundial y está aumentando el riesgo
de una hecatombe nuclear.
The Sun)
Ahora bien, Europa del Este no es el único
lugar donde los intereses estadounidenses
están en peligro.
Corea del Norte continúa amenazando a Corea
del Sur y Japón.
Kim Jong-un se niega a negociar su programa
nuclear con Washington y continúa probando
misiles como quien se prueba unas camisetas.
Otro tanto puede decirse de Irán, que está
a un paso de enriquecer uranio al nivel necesario
para fabricar armas nucleares según los inspectores
de la agencia atómica de la ONU.
Pero esperad un momento, porque si en la última
década alguien se ha convertido en el mayor
quebradero de cabeza en Washington, sabéis
perfectamente que ese contrincante no es otro
que China.
Pekín ha invertido un pastizal en su Ejército
y ha reforzado su poder nuclear.
Y como os explicamos hace meses en otro video,
la gran obsesión de Xi Jinping es la anexión
de Taiwán, aliado estadounidense y clave
en el mercado mundial de semiconductores.
Tampoco podemos olvidar que la influencia
china se ha extendido mucho más allá del
continente asiático y que sus relaciones
con Moscú atraviesan por su mejor momento.
Así que el mundo continúa cambiando y no
precisamente a favor de Washington.
Para evitar que el nuevo Imperio Romano de
Occidente caiga otra vez ante los bárbaros,
la Casa Blanca tiene mucho que aprender de
la época clásica.
(Quien desea la paz, debe prepararse para
la guerra.
Flavio Vegecio, siglo IV.)
Tener unas fuerzas armadas imponentes serviría
para disuadir a los enemigos de actuar.
Así que en la Casa Blanca ya se están preguntando
si el Ejército estadounidense cumple con
esta función y está preparado para hacer
frente a todas estas amenazas.
Por lo tanto, ahora la pregunta es ¿en qué
situación están actualmente las fuerzas
armadas de Estados Unidos?
¿Cuáles son sus principales puntos fuertes
y donde podrían encontrarse sus debilidades?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de Historia.
T1( UNA MODERNIZACIÓN PENDIENTE)
Las Fuerzas Armadas de Estados Unidos son
el Paris Saint-Germain del mundo militar.
Con mucha, muchísima diferencia nadie gasta
tanto.
Ahora bien, la cuestión es la misma para
ambos: ¿El pastizal que se pulen cada año
lo están invirtiendo donde realmente lo necesitan?
Y aquí las opiniones discrepan.
La historia nos muestra que el Ejército estadounidense
se renueva cada 40 años.
Lo hizo entre los años 30 y 40 del pasado
siglo, en los albores de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial.
También lo hizo entre los años 70 y 80,
cuando entraron en servicio las armas que
llevaron al Ejército estadounidense a la
cima del poderío militar.
Son las conocidas como Big Five y estoy seguro
que habéis oído hablar de todas ellas: el
tanque Abrams, el vehículo de combate de
infantería Bradley, el helicóptero de ataque
Apache, el helicóptero utilitario Black Hawk
y el sistema de misiles Patriot.
Pues bien, tras la caída de la Unión Soviética
y con el mundo en relativa paz, el Pentágono
inició a finales de los 90 una serie de programas
innovadores de renovación del armamento.
Con lo que nadie contaba es que en un solo
día el futuro cambiaría para siempre.
Hablamos por supuesto del 11 de septiembre
de 2001.
(Los ataques terroristas contra las Torres
Gemelas y el Pentágono llevaron al presidente
George Walker Bush a iniciar dos guerras prácticamente
al mismo tiempo.
Las operaciones militares de Afganistán e
Irak fueron un éxito al derrocar en unas
pocas semanas a los talibanes y al régimen
de Saddam Hussein.
Sin embargo, las tropas estadounidenses quedaron
atrapadas en dos conflictos interminables
contra diversos grupos armados, algo que ha
exigido continuos recursos humanos y económicos
y ha supuesto un enorme desgaste político.)
Según el proyecto Costs of War de la Universidad
de Brown, las guerras de Afganistán e Irak
han consumido más de 4 billones de dólares.
Así que, a medida que ambos conflictos se
enquistaban, los mandos militares se vieron
obligados a renunciar a sus superarmas del
futuro y centrarse, en cambio, en sacarle
el máximo partido al Big Five.
Por el camino se quedaron programas de modernización
como el Crusader, llamado a ser el obús autopropulsado
de nueva generación que necesitaba la artillería
estadounidense.
Pero esperad un momento, amigos, porque si
hay un proyecto que fue un auténtico fiasco,
ese fue el de Future Combat Systems, Futuros
sistemas de combate.
Lanzado en 2003 por la Administración Bush,
su objetivo era crear nuevas brigadas equipadas
con nuevos vehículos tripulados y no tripulados
conectados entre sí para actuar de una forma
rápida y flexible, sin precedente alguno.
El ejército de Estados Unidos aseguró que
era su mayor y más ambicioso programa desde
la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Sin embargo, la Administración Obama decidió
cancelarlo como parte de un cambio de estrategia
enfocado a gastar más en la lucha contra
el terrorismo y menos para prepararse para
la guerra convencional contra grandes estados
como China y Rusia.
Nada como este titular del año 2011 para
que os hagáis una idea de hasta qué punto
fracasó la modernización del Ejército estadounidense.
(Informe del ejército: las Fuerzas Armadas
han gastado 32.000 millones de dólares desde
el 95 en programas de armamento abandonados.
WashingtonPost)
Como os podéis imaginar, nadie sale a anunciar
un fracaso como este y se queda de brazos
cruzados.
El primer mandamiento de la comunicación
política es ofrecer una alternativa para
desviar la atención.
En este caso, para reemplazar alguno de los
cometidos del fallido programa Futuros Sistemas
de Combate, se diseñó el programa Ground
Combat Vehicle, Vehículo de combate terrestre.
Su objetivo era desarrollar un vehículo de
combate blindado de última generación para
reemplazar al Bradley.
Pero el Ejército canceló también este programa
5 años después debido a las restricciones
presupuestarias introducidas en 2011.
Y así hasta hoy, porque relevar al Bradley
continúa siendo una auténtica máquina de
triturar billetes.
Mirad:
(El ejército gastará al menos 1.500 millones
de dólares solo en prototipos para el tercer
intento de reemplazar el vehículo de combate
Bradley.
Taskandpurpose)
La Administración Obama aprobó en 2011 la
BCA, la Ley de Control Presupuestario, que
tuvo consecuencias notables para el Presupuesto
del Departamento de Defensa dentro de los
esfuerzos de la Casa Blanca para reducir el
aumento del déficit tras la Gran Recesión.
Esta Ley de Control Presupuestario estableció
topes de gasto durante 10 años, por lo que
ha estado vigente hasta 2021.
No es el momento de discutir si esta Ley era
necesaria o no.
Pero sí podemos decir que ha sido un obstáculo
para la modernización del Ejército estadounidense,
tal y como durante todos estos años quedo
reflejado en noticias como esta:
(El gasto en defensa debe superar los límites
de la Ley de Control Presupuestario para la
modernización nuclear, según un informe.
Defensedaily)
Y claro, si en todo este tiempo el Pentágono
no ha hecho los deberes y las amenazas no
han dejado de crecer, estos dos hechos combinados
nos indican que la no hace tanto considerada
como la gran superpotencia militar podría
tener problemas si los acontecimientos se
precipitaran en contra de sus intereses.
¿De qué tipo de problemas estamos hablando?
Pues…
Atentos.
(UNA HERENCIA INSUFICIENTE)
Hace 6 años Trump dio un nuevo giro a la
Estrategia de Seguridad Nacional de Estados
Unidos.
La Casa Blanca volvía a enfocarse hacia la
preparación del megaconflicto contra las
grandes potencias enemigas: China y Rusia.
Este cambio ha sido respaldado por Biden y
también por Vladimir Putin.
La guerra de alta intensidad ha vuelto, tal
y como nos ha enseñado la invasión rusa
de Ucrania.
Pues bien, la Fundación Heritage elabora
cada año un informe en el que evalúa el
estado actual de las fuerzas armadas de Estados
Unidos.
Ahora mismo se está prestando un apoyo brutal
a Ucrania, cifrado en más de 27.000 millones
de dólares en equipos y suministros militares.
Reponer los inventarios será complicado según
Dakota Wood, responsable del informe de la
Fundación Heritage.
Fijaos.
Según Dakota Wood, Estados Unidos ya ha proporcionado
a Ucrania un tercio de sus misiles antiaéreos
Stinger, así como más de un millón de proyectiles
de artillería y un tercio de su reserva total
de misiles antitanque Javelin.
No olvidéis que esta escasez de existencias
se está dando simplemente prestando ayuda
a Ucrania.
Imaginad lo que exigiría un conflicto directo
contra un gigante como China.
Bueno, realmente no hace falta que os lo imaginéis,
porque ya hay expertos elaborando informes
al respecto.
(La industria armamentística de Estados Unidos
no está preparada para un conflicto con China,
según un informe.
WSJ)
Respecto a las Fuerzas Armadas, el informe
de la Fundación Heritage considera insuficiente
la capacidad de los cuerpos militares estadounidenses
para cumplir con las misiones que tienen encomendadas.
El informe se refiere fundamentalmente a una
cuestión de tamaño.
En cada conflicto importante desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial, Estados Unidos movilizó el
equivalente a 21 brigadas de fuerza terrestre,
el Cuerpo de Marines aproximadamente 15 batallones
y la Fuerza Aérea alrededor de 600 aviones
de combate.
En este sentido, la Fundación Heritage considera
que para asegurar los intereses estadounidenses
lo recomendable es tener una fuerza el doble
de grande.
Esto supondría que el Ejército de Tierra
dispusiera de 42 brigadas, cuando actualmente
tiene 31, los Marines 30 batallones, cuando
ahora tienen 22 y la Fuerza Aérea 1.200 cazas,
cuando actualmente apenas tiene la mitad.
Asimismo, la Armada requeriría de 400 barcos,
cuando su número ya ha bajado de 300.
(El informe de Heritage recuerda que en los
años 80, la Marina tenía casi 600 barcos
de los cuales permanecían desplegados aproximadamente
100.
En 2022 el número de embarcaciones desplegadas
se mantenía en unos 94, pero la flota total
ha disminuido a 298, con previsión de reducirse
a 280 en 2037.
La misma carga de trabajo sobre una flota
que es menos de la mitad significa que apenas
hay tiempo para el entrenamiento, la preparación
y el adecuado mantenimiento y renovación
al estar continuamente operativos.
)
Un problema similar existe en la Fuerza Aérea.
Según Heritage, durante la Guerra Fría los
pilotos de combate promediaban más de 300
horas de vuelo anuales.
Actualmente no llegan a 120 horas.
Asimismo, el Ejército de Tierra opera con
brigadas, pero enfoca su entrenamiento a un
nivel más reducido de compañías, asumiendo
que luego en combate todos se coordinarán
bien.
Y alguno estará pensando: ya bueno, pero
es que ese planteamiento de Heritage de estar
preparado para dos guerras es un poco exagerado.
¿No?
Bueno, cada uno que piense lo que quiera.
Pero mirad lo que argumentó ante el Senado
el Almirante Richard, comandante del Comando
Estratégico de Estados Unidos hasta su retirada
el pasado diciembre.
Mucha gente piensa que invertir en Defensa
es una pérdida de dinero ya que estaría
mejor destinarlo a programas sociales porque
nunca pasa nada.
Pero bueno, quizás nuestros espectadores
de Ucrania podrían darnos su opinión al
respecto.
Actualmente, el presupuesto de Defensa de
Estados Unidos asciende a más de 800.000
millones de dólares.
Veamos ahora cuáles son sus grandes apuestas.
T3(PREPARA LA CARTERA OTRA VEZ, SAM)
El panorama internacional ha cambiado por
completo en el último año.
Rusia invadió Ucrania y China cada vez amenaza
más a Taiwán.
Los enemigos de Estados Unidos están pasando
a la acción y en el Pentágono lo tienen
claro.
La modernización del Ejército estadounidense
no puede aplazarse más, tal y como indica
el general James McConville, actual jefe de
Estado mayor del Ejército de Estados Unidos.
Actualmente, una de las grandes apuestas del
Ejército estadounidense es el futuro vehículo
de combate opcionalmente tripulado.
Se está invirtiendo mucho en I+D+i porque,
claro, opcionalmente tripulado significa que
este vehículo podrá operar de forma autónoma,
una tarea que nunca se ha logrado y que nadie
tiene ni idea si se conseguirá ni cuánto
costará.
Una estimación eleva las cifras hasta los
46.000 millones de dólares, por lo que podría
acabar siendo o toda una revolución militar
o un fracaso de dimensiones nachovidalianas.
Ahora bien, la gran apuesta del Pentágono
es el F-35, el caza con el que pretenden dominar
los cielos y al que ya hemos dedicado varios
videos en VisualPolitik.
Tío Sam, prepara la cartera otra vez que
este juguete es de los caros.
(El Pentágono agrega 14.000 millones de dólares
al coste total del caza F-35 hasta los 412.000
millones de dólares.
Bloomberg)
Se van a adquirir 2.400 F-35, así que cada
uno saldrá por unos 160 millones de dólares,
un poquito más de lo que le costó Dembelé
al Barça.
En ambos casos aún está por comprobarse
si tanta inversión mereció la pena.
En cambio, si hablamos de la Armada, el programa
que ya está confirmado como un fracaso es
el de los buques de Combate Litoral, que se
están empezando a retirar apenas 13 años
después de entrar en servicio por sus elevados
costes de operación al necesitar casi el
doble de tripulación de lo previsto.
Ahora se pretende enmendar este programa fallido
con la fragata lanzamisiles de la clase Constellation.
La primera fragata no llegará hasta 2026
y el programa ya acumula 2.000 millones de
dólares de sobrecoste hasta los casi 11.000
millones de dólares.
Pero bueno, la frase más repetida en el Pentágono
es la misma que en Parque Jurásico: “No
hemos reparado en gastos”.
Mirad.
Efectivamente, Estados Unidos gasta en defensa
más que los siguientes 10 países que más
gastan juntos.
Pero es que la modernización requiere de
inversión.
De hecho, uno de los ámbitos que pide a gritos
modernizarse es el de sus Fuerzas Nucleares.
Durante años se han limitado a extender la
vida útil de sus equipos.
Actualmente el Pentágono está desarrollando
el Sentinel, su nuevo misil balístico intercontinental,
que debería estar operativo en 2029.
De no tener éxito este programa, Estados
Unidos verá reducida su capacidad de disuasión
nuclear.
Mientras tanto, a nivel político la apuesta
del presidente Biden es el AUKUS.
(AUKUS es una alianza militar entre Australia,
Reino Unido y Estados Unidos.
El pacto tiene en su punto de mira a la Armada
de China, la más grande del mundo.
AUKUS busca incrementar la implicación de
la Casa Blanca y Downing Street en los asuntos
del Pacífico.
De este modo, Estados Unidos y Reino Unido
ayudarán a Australia a hacerse con una flota
de al menos 8 submarinos de propulsión nuclear,
capaces de operar con mayor alcance, resistencia
y sigilo.)
El nuevo enfoque hacia China está aumentando
considerablemente la inversión de Estados
Unidos en la región del Pacífico.
Se acaban de aprobar 87.000 millones de dólares
hasta 2028 que el Comando del Indo-Pacífico
piensa destinar a nuevas armas, construcciones
y a cooperar con los aliados en la región.
Una de las prioridades es reforzar la defensa
de la isla de Guam.
(Defendiendo la base militar estadounidense
de Guam, Lockheed potenciará el sistema de
armas Aegis para neutralizar los misiles del
Ejército chino.
Euroasiantimes)
El misil chino DF-26 es conocido como “el
asesino de Guam”, así que todo lo que instale
Estados Unidos para defender Guam está más
que justificado.
Y ahora la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que el Ejército estadounidense
está preparado para enfrentarse a China y
Rusia?
¿O pensáis que nunca habrá un choque directo
y sería mejor dedicar tantos millones de
dólares a otros asuntos?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.